a bottle and news Oh like a lot of
models Oh
Legos I was thinking Legos I'm thinking
of a theme park the b2 bomb filled with
hot people oh and you pay to get in you
still pay films office you pay by your
looks to get in oh if you're hot you
getting really [ __ ] free yep she's
really free yeah real cute again it but
if you're like you know whatever it's
like a Hollister whatever it's shelling
out it just sounds like a strip club but
reverse right oh yes yeah yeah Tyra
Banks is opening up a theme park in
California wait what am I missing
how is she five heads she really does
really she's known for that I've never
noticed that pulls it off though yeah it
doesn't take away from her beauty I'm
sooo busy looking at her eyes man I know
she never aims well she's wearing like
Oprah levels of makeup right there Sam
will you see some candids of Oprah and
then you see her on the magazine like
what there's like drywall plaster yeah
dude no joke man they probably put on
six inches of [ __ ] it solid ground up
babies are there rub on their face for
you that's what I hear it's like geisha
level yeah billionaire level yeah Tara
banks announced recently if she's
developing a 21 thousand square foot
theme park in Santa Monica
that's calling it muddled then and if
that's open late this year
damn that's huge I wonder where she
found land in Santa Monica
it's like multi-level and it's at one of
the shopping centers Oh Santa Monica
oh that third Street Promenade or like
that one mom like that that's pretty
cool yeah
model and so it goes up like a parking
structures which is she's kind of genius
because the way ice the way I kind of
picture this model land is like you know
how everyone's kind of a model these
days or just everyone's beauty levels
has upgraded because of like internet
and everything but I pictured this as
like an Ikea for models right you walk
in in the fur
thing you do is you [ __ ] take a
shower the next thing you do is like you
get your [ __ ] makeup on the next
thing you do get your hair did and then
like the next thing you do you get your
clothes done and the next thing you do
is like different themes of photoshoots
so it's like a full makeover plus a
photo she's Jetsons conveyor belt with
but like for models okay yeah like it
cool yeah I don't know if that's the
truth but that's what I'm at here no
it's gonna be at this place I've no idea
that's it it's the beginning of third
Street yeah he parked oh yeah it's like
it's gonna be yeah Papa it's on JC
Penney's inside of that yeah she's not
giving a lot of weight so I'm keeping it
really secret but she's just saying that
she wants this attraction to be for
everyone it doesn't it's not only for
models of all ages people of all ages of
all sizes of all everything what's the
attraction how people other attractions
how people know yes you say that they're
gonna be using like technology to make
everyone feel the best versions of
themselves I don't know what that means
like snapchat but what they have to
change you to make you look like the hot
version of yourself yeah good I'll give
them that good message yeah yeah she's
saying that it's not really high tech
[ __ ] to make you look like something you
like she said to be the dream version of
themselves that's the thing so it's
gonna include interactive entertainment
retail dining and user-generated content
she said it's not gonna be one of those
pop-up cuz it sounds like a Volvo yeah
it sounds like I put a restaurant next
to a storm and a pop of it all at the
same time just one thing she said it's
not gonna be one of those pop-ups where
you just go and take pictures
kind of like the Museum of ice cream do
you like those kind of places where you
just go and take photos that's exactly
where it's gonna be is exactly what I'm
thinking like they always do yeah it's
like here's what it's not is what its
gonna be game-changing
yeah all of that and she says that she
envisioned this to be a franchise so
it's gonna be locations all over the
world but the first one's gonna be here
in Santa Monica revolutionizing the path
I hope it becomes Beauty land my
concepts [ __ ] better than that [ __ ]
and at the end there's a roller coaster
and a log ride just blast all the stuff
that you like on your
our wrinkles our shirt splashed water
all over it
you come in raggedy and then you feel
like a yeah you can sell me anything if
you say there's a long run you get the
period there's a log ride that's what
makes it a theme park but in this case
it's not a log it's a big [ __ ]
lipstick of course my man yeah and it's
sliding down a canal where at the end of
the budget vagina hole lips would have
made a lot more sense
the lipstick goes into the general that
makes no sense
typical storage for shoots out of the
vagina you're thinking of different lips
that's why yeah I don't know how it
works yeah so now everyone's like it's
gonna be all about she said she's
working on this for the past ten years
ten years
brainstorm that like three minutes she
was like she was talking about doing
something for ten years and they were
just like oh hey Museum of ice cream is
really successful I'll just like [ __ ]
throw model on that is what I this is my
biggest 21,000 square feet and it's a
half acre
JCPenney's like a Sears well it's
smaller than a Sears or did you pay yeah
well cuz I'm thinking like you stack a
couple floor dude that's like a Kmart or
like mm so maybe like ten of these oh
that's a good little Kmart or something
right yeah like it came on like a
regular Kmart watch it'd be like really
[ __ ] dope and then all of us get
moated s but hopefully it is good that'd
be dope dude this is part of my my
theory which is like Tyra Banks is hot
mm-hmm Tyra Banks like has has been
pretty has had a great career yes why
why has she had such a good career cuz I
mean she sticks to what she knows which
is modeling in that world no doubt but
she's also a model that can speak and
think she's smart all this [ __ ] Sanford
she had her America's Next Top Model a
book was a book about everyone has a
book books and then you look around
Hollywood you know what do you start
seeing you start saying like oh man how
people are doing pretty good people are
[ __ ] kicking ass so my whole thing is
like hot people privilege bro
a few hot people got it [ __ ] nature
of its true you if you're hot you can
probably get a job anywhere you could
know what nobody [ __ ] talks about
everyone talks about white privilege
[ __ ] stuff there's hot privilege it
the [ __ ] up
right it just means shut up hey shut up
stop talking you have white privilege
you're oppressed by the hot people we're
all oppressed by the hot people but we
haven't United yet that's because
there's a delusion of people people
think that they're hot they don't know
hot people what do you got against a
Steve and they're like you're not part
of this right I don't know what you talk
about Steve I'm hot as [ __ ] and I never
get opportunities Yeah right like well
maybe because you're not hot have you
ever been fairly rated and not just by
yourself in the mirror right do people
always swipe left or right on tinder for
you I would like to buy that you know
you know beauty is in the eye of the
beholder remember that be cool if
they're gonna be really a lot of people
would hate this but that'd be cool if
there was like some sort of reading
system I feel like the general public
would reach you as if that sounds like a
black bear oh yeah no I feel like that's
Institute which I know that's pretty
good that's what the following shows you
you things up no I don't know well you
know how like like different tribes they
like to put plates on their lip or like
they're here and that's [ __ ] hot or
like the long neck girls that's hot
right I wonder what they think when they
see our models in our idea are they like
look at titties that give even different
parts of the world yeah different
centers of beauty it's like but there's
a pretty universal standard in almost
every country yeah as far as like you
know when you look at the magazines all
[ __ ] you kind of see the same kind of
think you were telling me that guys are
attracted to there's a ratio yeah
there's a biological ratio actually so
but then though I mean the girls and get
bigger or skinnier but the racial kind
of stays the same
yeah but hot people when although in all
countries and territories what's the
ratio of hi I forgot what it was that I
learned in the class but there's an app
you mean like a waist or hip - titty
titty to waste - so even like you know
like guys that like thick chicks huh
they like thick chicks but there's still
the same
so as the guys that like super skinny
chicks it's still the same ratio it's
just a biological thing that we have I
don't even know what the ratio is for
super skinny no yeah like facial
features George Kontos I mean that's
preference but then they're just how am
I in terms of procreating there's like
your fertility needs the more
symmetrical the face is that's supposed
to be culturally like all over yeah
doesn't matter what culture yeah exactly
it's all biology and magazine covers you
see the symmetrical faces and all the
same kind of Jam mm-hmm no matter who
they are I don't know man hot people
privilege bro
yeah that's not true how is it not true
how people don't get the same respect
that no one how people get oh really
yeah they should cry into all their
money they're less likely to have
heavier sentences to yeah get it you
know I do get off with cops
yeah it just sounds like the ugly person
like hey oh yeah [ __ ] you [ __ ] yeah
privilege though it's not fair
ask me what my solution is I have none I
just wanna [ __ ] about it just like
every other does they kill all the
attractive people yeah that's what a
[ __ ] about it that's it so I was
watching daddy's home - and then you
know that really hot did you watch the
first one yeah okay I thought you were
skip around Ricky boy you know how to
keep Mark Wahlberg's married to the
model superhot model and then his
ex-wife is married to Kevin James okay
so anyway so then the ex-wife and then
the hot model they were shopping in the
hot model starts shoplifting and then
this ex-wife is like well my got a
couple your shoplifting like why are you
doing that and then the models like oh
it's like exhilarating you should try it
whatever and then the security guard
comes over you shoot the mall or the x-y
I thought that the models would be in
trouble but then the guard tells the
model like excuse me ma'am is she
bothering you oh really I don't know
they even highlighted in that movie so
funny but see the hot people have all
separated all of us in two different
camps - turns out a little bit naughty
that's right bro hot people eliminate
the Illuminati's we don't exactly
we don't see it fucking-a Luba hotties
they put us under a spell so we should
be pissed at you but instead we're so
enamoured by them and we make excuses
for them all that's true you'd say
maluma ha
like if a hot chick cuts me off in
traffic and I see that she's hot I'm
like you know it's ridiculous that's
true they trick us
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]